welcome to this video Venegas Oh from
Mexico Mexico yeah just that just
fianchetto and see where we go from
there the double fianchetto it's not
that bad really this is one point okay
getting some some counter play now in
the center with my pawns let's see
that's six me yeah the only issue is
that this is all nice and good but it's
probably leading to lot's of trades and
at the end it's probably really boring
yeah maybe I can go look c8 first and
then think about taking on your form
yeah I screen us a little bit a little
bit awkwardly placed I mean no problem
or whatever but I have no reason to to
take oakley I know now he is getting a
bit nervous about the Queen and Tim and
moves moves it so going to take here or
not I guess it's hard to keep this
tension forever
yeah a seven was hanging yeah that's
obviously not very exciting I wanted to
play this double fianchetto to get
something more unconventional but this
is as boring as it gets Oh f3 yeah this
gives me some hope not that it is
terribly bad but it at least weakens
stuff oh no he weakens asleep on those
two most played really quickly and
they're both harm is position surprising
okay so Queen here too and check c 4 and
a 2
you
yeah this h5 is this is something
serious it's not like completely
completely pointless so have to be
careful also after rook takes c4 it is a
kind of a self pen but I still will take
I would have be five to protect so here
I can play and must play be five that
was surprising was how quickly if this
went downhill for white
yeah f3 and before this was really
showing that he didn't have any patience
I guess for this type of position it was
totally equal really if he just just
stays let's aim and play and play some
normal normal moves okay if I go Lucas
III he has going to you for maybe don't
know I mean probably not a bad idea to
to trade something
q
hmm it's um that's not so great actually
hmm what did I do advice how do I defend
this it's a little bit this is awkward
27 26 maybe
not good yeah everything of Queenie six
possible in f 650 km
preparing 26
yeah trying to enter the Supreme move
so queen is six now right f6 this is
what is the cs does he have any counter
attack I really don't see it maybeee for
you but then Quincy eight yeah f6 is I
think this is this is generally useful
you
Chansey I could play rook see to hear to
to trade trade Queens but not sure I
brought the merit of this idea maybe
just invade here with the rock okay one
rookie to this kind of thing is a little
bit this is liable liability this up to
five always has to to cover the Queen
my idea is now Queen c8 and then
invasion oh ok that's a dangerous
diagonal
yeah i think my rock receive one and
then invade with the Queen it should be
should be okay right he tries to tries
to enter
I was those chicks and he has got 25
okay you had the chick see how immensely
irritating Jack can check here this is
the problem queen bee three check check
but I really didn't see what I should do
them growl ahead it's hard to not take
it ma from this position I he was really
killing himself he and I didn't win no
ahh this hurts this really hurts and so
this must have been ok right where did I
why did I screw that up maybe Mary I
mean I was playing it a little bit lame
Mia no not in terms of time spent i mean
in terms of move quality I cook age 100
that's really easy if I get the porn
it's it's over okay and it was very
simple but this is of course also
winning why didn't I win here I can take
the porn simply you know what my problem
was I I saw actually I saw this kind of
thing and I thought it should be a win
but I overlooked that he always does
this check also the queen bee three
check is a big problem I wanted to go
here this was my original intention to
grab the pawn but he has this check lack
I forgot this check and this is a
perpetual now and for
claim yeah this is a shame always a bit
frustrating because well I know this is
this is the first move that it's
completely unnecessary but it's not
hurting but he played this in two
seconds and this is just to suggest a
gross position an area before it's just
just bad after that the only one playing
for something is black because I have
the c4c for target and i mean that i
wanted so quickly was not necessary
really but stop it was before some is an
indication that he didn't you yeah you
just have to play a slow move be three
or something and then stay and before
it's the kind of move that says okay i'm
willing to lose the game if you if you
play right I mean he should maybe her
words whatever but it's totally
unnecessary to to make this weakness
here and after that you sort of want to
win the game yeah but didn't do it okay
thanks for watching